oh seconds that's all it takes for a
train to come off the tracks
like this one in Springfield Ohio it's
just one of the around a dozen
derailments already reported in 2023
according to the association of American
railroads over 1 000 trains derail every
year every single event that we
investigate is preventable and while not
all are severe derailments can happen in
many ways here are some of the biggest
reasons trains go off the tracks and
what can be done to make the system
safer
derailments are the most common train
accidents in the U.S in 2022 66 percent
of accidents were classified by the
Federal Railroad Administration as
derailments that's across all 600 plus
railroad companies in the country in
both Rail Yards where most derailments
happen and out on the main lines and
track issues are one of the biggest
causes that can be a track that's too
wide a broken rail or a warped track
essentially it's when the track isn't
ready for the train Michael Hiller is
the deputy director of the railroad
investigation office at the NTSB he
investigated this 2017 derailment in
grotinger Iowa where 20 cars of a Union
Pacific Train derailed at a bridge that
year 14 of derailments caused by track
issues were because of some sort of a
broken track piece the rail broke under
the middle of the train there's a
portion of the train that's on the other
side of the bridge and it's safe but
then there's a pile of cars and then
behind there's still a bunch of cars
that haven't derailed some cars released
ethanol causing the train to catch fire
the NTSB found that the track in the
area of the derailment was inadequately
maintained every time it hit that zone
it would just pound pound and pound that
rail until it eventually broke in 2013 a
catastrophic derailment in Bridge
kit was was so caused by a broken track
piece a Metro North passenger Train
derailed and collided with another train
injuring 65 people in this incident
compromised joint bars that connect two
different types of rail together were
fractured once that joint bar is broken
there's no longer a structure able to
support the safe movement of a train in
both cases the NTSB May
be maintenance and inspection but it's
ultimately up to the railroads to
implement them in response Metro North
updated its inspection protocol and says
it continues to maintain a robust track
inspection program and Union Pacific
says its inspection and maintenance
policies go above and beyond
requirements as a track wears it does
require inspection and it does require
maintenance and it's that inspection
that is really critical to identify what
types of interventions are necessary to
keep it operating safe track isn't the
only thing that breaks a among the major
Freight railroads equipment failures
were the most common cause of Mainline
derailments in 2022 that was the case in
the February derailment in East
Palestine Ohio the ntsb's preliminary
report said that an overheated wheel
bearing likely caused the Norfolk
Southern train to go off the tracks
Sparks under a rail car could be seen on
surveillance cameras miles before the
Train derailed 38 cars derailed
including 11 that were carrying
hazardous materials and caught fire
damaging 12 more the incident rattled
the town angering residents who still
worry about damages to the community
including fear of possible water
contamination we all just want answers I
think that's what everybody here wants
is just answers the Environmental
Protection Agency has said local
drinking water is safe it also ordered
Norfolk Southern to clean up the site
the railroad also announced new safety
initiatives like adding more temperature
sensors to its tracks to alert a train's
crew of any trouble before it's too late
inspection and new sensors alone can't
prevent all derailments many are caused
by human errors that can mean going too
fast miscommunication or misaligned
switches the NTSB has tried to address
human errors including pushing for
safeguards like positive train control
PTC is a system that helps to slow and
stop trains to prevent accidents like
collisions and overspeed derailments in
my time
I've had at least four investigations
where overspeeding in a curve resulted
in a derailment and a very catastrophic
outcome in 2008 Congress mandated that
every major railroad develop a PTC
system in the rail safety Improvement
act it took 12 years for all of the
railroads to fully Implement PTC spray
rail companies need to stop fighting us
every time we try to do a regulation
Norfolk Southern CEO said that the
company supports legislative efforts to
enhance rail safety in March a
bipartisan group of senators proposed
new legislation that would tighten
safety regulations and increase fines
but pushback is expected Industry Group
AAR criticized the proposed legislation
saying some regulations like crew size
requirements wouldn't prevent future
accidents
overall derailments are happening less
frequently than they were a decade ago
that's thanks in part two advances in
rail safety including positive train
control but for some railroads the rate
of derailments has increased in recent
years as they've moved more freight over
fewer miles
still compared to other modes of
transportation train travel is very safe
if you compare Highway versus rail the
loss of life is a lot greater on the
highway side versus rail Hillary thinks
there can be more improvements when it
comes to rail safety you have to have
good maintenance you have to have good
training you have to have good
organizations that really Embrace safety
as part of its culture it's achievable
but it's going to take a lot of work
foreign
[Music]